Nur Mut, mein Lieber.
Mein Chef, Herr Hochnäsig,
ist kein einfacher Mensch.
Unsinn! Kein Problem!
Ich weiß, wie wichtig sein Besuch für dich ist.
Er ist zu spät…
Herzlich willkommen, Herr Hochnäsig! Schön, dass es geklappt hat.
Vielen Dank für IhreGastfreundschaft, Frau Langnäsig.
Tut mir leid, aber ich habe kein Geschenk.
Ich hatte eines, aber mein Hund
hat es gestohlen und gefressen.
Ach, das macht doch nichts. Ich verstehe das. Ich habe auch einen Hund.
Darf ich Ihnen meinen Mann vorstellen?
Guten Tag, Herr Langnäsig. Sehr erfreut.
Kommen Sie rein.
Setzen Sie sich!
Fühlen Sie sich wie zu Hause!
Darf ich Ihnen ein Glas Sekt anbieten?
Es tut mir leid, aber ich trinke keinen Alkohol.
Oh je! Wir haben nur Wasser.
Das ist kein Problem!
Das ist eine Katastrophe! Was soll ich tun?
Mhm, das sieht aber lecker aus.
Und es riecht so gut.
Darf ich Ihnen von der Vorspeise geben?
Es ist nur eine Kleinigkeit, Salat mit
Mozzarella, Tomaten und Basilikum.
Nein, danke. Ich kann keinen Mozzarella essen.
Ich habe eine Laktose-Intoleranz.
Oh, das tut mir leid!
Da kann man leider nichts machen.
Ja, ja…
Oh, mein Gott! Wann wird das enden?!
Möchten Sie etwas von dem Huhn?
Nein, danke. Ich bin Vegetarier,
schon seit vielen Jahren.
Ah so! Oh, wie schade!
Etwas anderes kann ich Ihnen
leider nicht anbieten.
Dann haben wir ein Problem.
Dann halt nur Wasser.
Es hat wirklich ausgezeichnet geschmeckt.
Vielen Dank! Das freut mich.
Ich komme gleich zurück.
Entschuldigung, ich bin auch gleich wieder da.
Habbitte Geduld, mein Lieber.
Ich ertrage ihn jeden Tag bei der Arbeit.
Jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst!
So, und hier kommt die Hauptspeise.
Die Nudeln sind übrigens selbst gemacht.
Oh, nein! Ich bin allergisch gegen Weizen.
Mama!
Würden Sie Ihr Kind bitte beruhigen?
Ich kann schreiende Kinder nicht ausstehen.
Davon bekomme ich Kopfschmerzen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Entschuldigung, ich komme auch gleich zurück.
Ich weiß, dass es nicht einfach ist…
Nur noch eine Weile…
Er wird bald weg sein.
Oh Gott, wann...!
Nur Gott weiß es…
Darf ich Ihnen noch etwas Wasser nachschenken?
Nein, danke. Ich muss langsam gehen.
Es ist schon spät.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Kommen Sie gut nach Hause.
Noch einmal herzlichen Dank für die Einladung!
Ich habe lange nicht so gut gegessen.
Echt?! Gern geschehen.